we had a look at this shape right we
divide it up into geometric figures
mostly polygons simpson's rule does the
same thing but he does it
so much smarter it takes this idea
this shape here has a name does anyone
recognize it it's called a parabola
right we refer to this as a probably
going around the circumference of this
thing okay
so this has an equation y equals x
squared
okay that's what gives it the parabolic
shape
now what we can do is instead of using
these figures
which are all pretty blunt instruments
right what we can do is we can take this
shape and we can approximate it
with a series of problems a problem like
this
along with one like this and one like
this
and we can join together
a curvy kind of area
something like that this weird irregular
shape
using a series of parabolas right
simpson's rule it comes out as a formula
looks like this okay area is
approximately equal to so get this down
with me and then i'll show you how it
works
h on three times
okay so here's the formula and let me
explain it to you
okay what we're going to do is we're
going to divide this area up not in
in this kind of fashion but in a more
regular way let me give you an example
i've already done this
okay
okay so the first thing we're going to
do and actually i will ask you now to
help me refocus would you do that would
you
make sure it can see there all right so
clicks on the screen so you can see make
sure it's if i go down that's fine
so what i've done here is i've got my
irregular area and i've sliced all the
way across
it it's kind of like a diagonal like for
a rectangle but
i could draw a whole bunch of other
lines i could draw it from here to here
and i would also get a diagonal it's an
irregular shape so it's not going to
follow the same rules down normal shapes
and then across this diagonal i'm going
to divide up the area into a bunch of
perpendicular
like this
all right can you see what i've done you
see what i've done yeah
so what i've got here is a series of
lines that run perpendicular to my
diagonal
okay i need to know what number one all
of these sections
are right so those are my h's
h stands for height
okay h for height so you can pop it down
on there right
and then i've got all of these
perpendicular values
they are all of the x values x1
x2 x3 okay so suppose i want to give you
a simplified version of this
shape
okay there you go all right now what
i've got is
let's put a couple of extras what i've
got is
i've divided this up we need to make
this a bit longer
boys this is your time
and it's my time and i'm not keen to
waste it
the drawing was like did you take it off
that drawing i just drew a whole new
thing
so here's what i'm gonna do the h's are
these distances
can you see they're all roughly the same
okay so they're the height of each of
these sections
okay and then what i've got is these
distances
here that run perpendicular to the
diagonal
x1 x2 x3
now either with a triangle wheel or
with the scale that you've already been
provided at an aerial view
i'm going to have to measure what these
distances are and then i'm going to
feed them into this formula so let me
give you an example
let's just estimate let's just estimate
okay
how far you've got you've got to scale
down here that's 10 meters apparently
how far do you think this is what would
you guess
just have a look at it 30 20.
35 let's just let's call 30 because it's
an easy number
it might be somewhat you can do it more
precisely so i'm going to have
30 on 3. 30 on 3.
i'm going to ask you to help me do a bit
more estimation right
this is going to be longer right what do
you reckon you want to call it
it's probably a bit much i think like
it's about
i'd say maybe 50 we're pretty close
again all of this is things that you're
gonna have a look at more
in more detail so there's the first
measurement
okay okay this next one in here
this is longer right what do you reckon
70 70 i'm gonna call seven
so we're measuring these lines that run
perpendicular
these guys that run perpendicular to the
diagonal
okay now i'm going to do just one more
just one more this one here okay if i
wanted to keep going i could add on more
values right
this one seems to be the longest of a
lot 90
let's just let's just get a hundred
right now again you're going to get some
actual numbers for these
right now i'm actually just going to
evaluate now these are really easy
numbers so we didn't even need a
calculator for most of this i reckon
30 on three ten fifty plus four times
seventy is
280 280 280 plus 150 that sounds like
400
4 300 square meters
does that sound right
that's a really big number isn't it yeah
does it sound reasonable
no i'll come back i'll come back from
the top
here's our formula by the way just
saying if any of you go ahead and you
choose two unit or three
mass or above right this formula
actually gets proved
we show you how a parabola gives you
that for now we don't need that
we just need to work out the numbers
okay you can pop this into a spreadsheet
i can show you how in a second
and this next line here we're just
estimating these distances
based on our eye and the scale that's
provided to us
you can go in way more detail by
actually doing the pixels because you've
got the map there
you've got the map and then we simply
substituted
what were these heights we estimated
about 30 meters
what were these perpendicular distances
and that's where these numbers
come from we punched it in that's what
we got
now keep in mind i only went this far
it's not the whole thing
right that's only this middle section so
if i wanted to do the whole thing
i'd use more values okay but simpson's
rule will do it with more precision
than just doing rectangle here
semicircle there
all those kinds of things